no I was making over 10,000 a month you
just don't expect the good time stay in
it's just part of living in West Texas
it was me and another guy working
we made this company a lot of money we
had constant jobs you know job after job
after job after job he had come up to me
with concerns aw man the oil prices
going down I said but we're the only
ones working man we're making this
company money there's no way in the
world they're gonna get rid of us we're
the first ones to go so it hit us you
know out of nowhere
I told my fiancee
don't worry about it girl I'm gonna find
another job six seven months later I was
still sitting on that damn couch looking
for a job is the hardest time of my life
when you've kind of invested your life
in it you're pretty ill-prepared to go
to another job to try to find a new
career
people think that their that they mean
so much to the company or that they've
been there for so long or that they put
in their time and do all these different
things that does those things just go
out the window
I was in it for 17 years before I got
laid off it's like a part of me is
missing not being in the hole the
hardest thing was was realizing that the
whole industry turned its back on me if
a company is seeing six-digit seven
digit losses they they just they can't
keep people and that's exactly what
happened to us in the 80s it's what
happened to us again this time seeing
all these all these yards up through
here I mean use there's no vehicles
you know just out there it was just dead
the first of the year we lost our
biggest client and that was 25 percent
of our sales right off the bat I got a
little nervous you know I knew something
was coming not only do I have you know
three kids and then one on the way and
my mom take care of you know and my
employees know everybody you know feels
the heat and these times this is when
you got to hunker down now right here
you'll see all these rigs stacked you
know hundreds of thousands of dollars a
day and fees and jobs for each one of
those just sitting out there
the money just flows whenever things are
good and then when times are bad it's
completely like shutting off the oxygen
there just is nothing there you've got a
home you've got cars you've got kids in
college you've got you know whatever it
might be and and all of a sudden your
entire livelihood is completely jerked
out from under you there's definitely no
way to emotionally prepare for that I
almost gave up but then the thoughts of
my daughter and my fiance would comment
you know overthrow them thoughts I mean
there's no telling where I'd be right
now if it wasn't for them when you see
people that are so excited over the low
gasoline prices at the pump you hope
that that they will kind of understand
that there's there's a human toll Big
Oil is made up of so many small people
who were working from sunup to sundown
just trying to put food on the table and
do the best that they can do it's not
big oil that gets hurt it's us